brought to you by Assassin's Creed unity
make history with friends available
November 11
hey guys it is the tenth of November
today my name is Jess McDonald and this
is some games but knees first up it
seems that playing games can get you a
relationship or fiancee in this case
eyewear is written on their blog that
they created a custom level in the
upcoming Mass Effect to help one of
their fans Jackie propose to a partner
Amy who are both massive fans of the
series under the pretense of consumer
testing Amy played through the level
complete with subtle references to their
relationship which culminated in a
message appearing on a console at the
end at the level which prompted the
proposal which happened in real life she
said yes too so it's all coming up
Paragon apparently Call of Duty is the
best franchise ever that's according to
the Guinness Book of World Records 5,000
gamers from 140 countries were asked
about their favorite game for the
Guinness World Records 2015 games
edition according to the independent of
those games within collated to determine
who topped the franchise list if you're
a stickler for proper data collection
you're probably bothered by the tiny
sample size and the fact that a favorite
game does not equal your favorite
franchise suspending those questionable
points though call of duty top the list
followed up by super mario brothers
minecraft GTA and their halo and the
legend of zelda you can check out the
full list of 50 franchises on gamespot
thousands creed unity is set to be a
technical powerhouse according to its
creative director Alex a Mon cher
recently spoke on major nelson radio to
explain that they've harnessed every
ounce of power from both consoles as
much as we could said power harnessing
has enabled over 5,000 npcs on screen
after time where previous instalments
could only facilitate 200 Omashu says
one scene even features 10,000
interactive on screen and PCs unity will
also feature lighting advancements
improvements to textures and for the
first time no loading screens the game
also boasts that one in four of its
buildings is fleshed out with an
interior
and inhabitants and the in-game Paris
will feature a lot of the landmarks
you'd hope to see ask you a question of
the day let me know down in that comment
box which franchise you think deserves
the title of best franchise ever if
you're looking for more news you can
head to gain spot and find stories on
batman arkham knight and i'll pick the
game of the month for october that is it
for me today be sure to subscribe to us
on youtube and i'll be back tomorrow
with a bunch more stories